die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg willkommen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem Sonntag
an meiner Seite ist wieder Norbert
Lehmann für den Sport
und das sind die Themen von heute
G7 im krisenmodus in Japan beraten die
Außenminister über Spannungen in Asien
und den Ukraine Krieg
Kompass in die Zukunft auf der Hannover
Messe dreht sich alles ums vernetzte
arbeiten und um nachhaltige Produktion
und was für ein Handballkrimi im
Siebenmeter werfen bezwingen die
Rhein-Neckar Löwen Magdeburg und holen
den DHB-Pokal
drei Tage lang beraten die Außenminister
der sieben führenden Industrienationen
im Japan Schwerpunkt ist der Ukraine
Krieg es gehe darum Putin unsere
Entschlossenheit zu zeigen dass er seine
Ziele auch nicht durch Zermürbung
erreichen werde sagte Außenministerin
Werbung heute ging es aber vor allem um
China seine umstrittene Haltung zu
Russland und seine Drohungen in Richtung
Taiwan Andreas Künast berichtet
dass Leute hasten müssen um ihren Zug zu
kriegen bekommen die Pendler am Bahnhof
in Tokio jeden Tag zu sehen aber nicht
wie einige der mächtigsten Außenminister
der Welt an ihnen vorbei hassten gerade
noch so erreichen Deutschland und die
USA den Schnellzug in dem ein g7-treffen
voller Fragen beginnt die wichtigste was
tun mit China die Europäer haben mit
Peking geredet die Amerikaner haben
Peking gedroht aber die Sorge vor einem
Krieg mit taiwan ist nicht kleiner
geworden
Außenministerin bärburg wirbt im
ZDF-Interview für Deutschlands
überfällige neue china-strategie wir
haben im letzten Jahr auf brutale Art
und Weise gesehen was passiert wenn wir
glauben Handel allein sei schon eine
Strategie das war es leider nicht und
wir mussten dafür ein wahnsinnig hohen
Preis bezahlen mit Sorge sehen die G7
das konträr zu ihrem Schulterschluss
auch der zwischen China und Russland
enger wird Werburg berichtet nach ihrem
PE kingbesuch von besorgniserregend und
harmonischen Tönen
der Westen tut sich schwer mit China in
der EU gibt es von mehr Härte gibt es
mehr Dialog jede Meinung und in der
Ampel Koalition auch drei Tage lang
wollen die Außenminister in karowitz
aber zumindest ihre Einigkeit beschwören
und versuchen einen weiteren Krieg
diesmal in Asien zu verhindern
das komplette Interview mit der
Außenministerin sehen sie gleich nach
uns in Berlin direkt heute feiert die
orthodoxe Kirche Ostern trotzdem
bombardiert Russland weiter die Ukraine
zumindest eine erfreuliche Nachricht zum
Osterfest beide Seiten haben erneut
Gefangene ausgetauscht russland habe 130
ukrainische Soldaten Matrosen und
Grenzschützer freigelassen teilte Kiew
mit wie viele russische Soldaten im
Austausch zurück in ihre Heimat dürfen
ist nicht bekannt
jetzt in den Sudan dort sprechen Ärzte
mittlerweile von dutzenden Toten und
hunderten verletzten seit gestern gibt
es vor allem in der Hauptstadt cartoon
massive Gefechte zwischen Armee und
Paramilitärs beide teilten sich bisher
die Macht in dem afrikanischen Land
jetzt sollte der Übergang zu einer
gewählten Zivilregierung stattfinden
stattdessen Gewalt goldene erteil
berichtet
Kämpfe am Flughafen der Hauptstadt
Traktoren diese Aufnahmen sind von
gestern aber auch heute berichten
Einwohner von dichten Rauchwolken über
der Stadt
am Morgen waren laute Explosionen zu
hören die Intensität der
Auseinandersetzungen habe nicht
nachgelassen sagen uns Augenzeugen im
Gegenteil
immer mehr Geschosse landen in Büros
oder Wohnungen
diese Schüler können seit gestern nicht
die Schule verlassen es gibt kaum Strom
kaum Wasser kaum Internet sich zu
versorgen sei oft lebensgefährlich hören
wir aus ratum
am Abend eine dreistündige Feuerpause
Einwohner holen sich Brot
die Kämpfe finden statt mitten in
Wohngebieten ein Panzer fährt über ein
Auto
Sudans Ärzteverband meldet dutzende tote
Zivilisten
bereits eine sehr hässliche Situation
ich bin mir sicher dass wir nicht die
richtigen Todeszahlen sehen weder auf
dem Schlachtfeld noch bei den Zivilisten
die mittendrin gefangen sind
Zivilisten die ihrer politischen Führung
ausgeliefert sind zwei Generäle bekannt
für Verbrechen und Gräueltaten die ihre
Macht eigentlich bald abgeben sollten an
eine zivile Regierung und sich nun
bekriegen
nicht nur ist die Hoffnung auf ein Ende
der Militärherrschaft zerbrochen die
Gefahr ist nun das andere bewaffnete
Gruppen im Sudan und in den unruhigen
Nachbarländern in den Konflikt
hineingezogen werden
was kann Technologie für den Klimaschutz
leisten wie kann künstliche Intelligenz
helfen wie
energieeffizienter genutzt werden alles
Themen der Hannover Messe auf dieser
wichtigsten Industrieschau der Welt
präsentieren Firmen ihre Innovationen
vor einer Stunde hat der Bundeskanzler
die Messe eröffnet mal in ilau hat mehr
CO2-neutrale Produktion künstliche
Intelligenz und wasserstofftechnologien
das sind die leithemen der diesjährigen
Industriemesse Klima und
Ressourcenschutz eine modellfabrik von
Festo macht aus Algen einen
Biokraftstoff was wir hinter mir sehen
ist die sogenannte Bionic selfactory ein
Bioreaktor mit dem wir zeigen wie wir
auch in der Lage sind biologische
Prozesse zu automatisieren die
Industriemesse Hannover will sich als
globale Klimaschutz Leitmesse
positionieren denn die Industrie
verbraucht ca 45% Stroms in Deutschland
Hannover Messe 2023 wird zeigen dass
nicht nur die deutschen Aussteller
sondern weltweit das Thema einer
klimaneutralen Industrieproduktion
absolutes Ziel ist und das ist ganz
konkrete Lösungen hierzu gibt
deutschland hat sich verpflichtet bis
2045 CO2-neutral zu werden die Industrie
sieht nach eine wichtige Rolle soll
dabei aus erneuerbaren Energien
gewonnener Wasserstoff spielen
indonesien ist dieses Jahr Partnerland
und setzt ebenso auf den Aufbau einer
Wasserstoffwirtschaft und gute
Handelsbeziehungen durch die
Industriemesse Susanne gute Tradition
dass sie immer wieder stattfindet
zusammen mit wichtigen Partnerländern
diesmal Indonesien und auch großen
Themen wie was zu tun haben mit dem
industriellen Aufbruch den wir in
Deutschland Vorhaben mehr als 4000
Aussteller präsentieren Lösungen für die
Produktion und Energieversorgung der
Zukunft mit dem Ziel den CO2-Fußabdruck
zu verringern
auch die Industrie leidet unter
Fachkräftemangel der ist so groß wie nie
in Deutschland im vergangenen Jahr
konnten 630.000 Stellen nicht besetzt
werden so dass Institut der deutschen
Wirtschaft besonders dramatisch ist die
Lage in den Bereichen Gesundheit
soziales und Erziehung dringend gesucht
werden auch Naturwissenschaftler und
Informatiker
vor 78 Jahren befreiten US-Truppen des
Konzentrationslager Buchenwald mit einer
Gedenkfeier wurde der Opfer der
nazi-gräuel gedacht im Mittelpunkt heute
die Verfolgung der Sinti und Roma und
3.500 Angehörige der Minderheit waren
von den Nazis nach Buchenwald
verschleppt worden
Thüringens Ministerpräsident ramelomante
es sei wichtig zu erinnern und die
Geschichte weiter aufzuarbeiten
und jetzt zum Handball Norbert und zum
Pokal Krimi in Köln das spannende geht
es echt nicht die Rhein-Neckar Löwen
gegen Magdeburg vor 20.000 begeisterten
Zuschauer 60 packende Minuten reguläre
Spielzeit dann Verlängerung schließlich
die Entscheidung im 7 Meter werfen am
Ende schnappen sich die Löwen den Pokal
die dramatologie hätte ausgereifter kaum
sein können und der Mannheimer
Siegesjubel kaum ausgelassener dabei
waren es die Magdeburger die 7 Sekunden
vor Schluss der regulären Spielzeit den
Pokal eigentlich schon in Händen hielten
doch der niederländerkreis mit verbaut
und sorgte damit für die zweimal 5
minütige Verlängerung doch auch die
beließ es beim Unentschieden und führte
in sieben Meter werfen in dem der
Schulter der Rhein-Neckar Löwen Joel
Berlin den vierten Magdeburger Straße 5
parieren konnte und und so sorgte der
Schwede Albin Lager green mit dem
letzten verwandelten sieben Meter für
die Entscheidung
für die Mannheimer ist es der zweite
Erfolg im dab-pokal während der Meister
aus Magdeburg weiterhin auf den ersten
Pokal warten muss
im ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer unterliegt
Bremen Freiburg mit 1 zu 2 Werder 1
runter auf Tabellenplatz 12 der SC
bleibt fünfter ja alle Tore alle
Höhepunkte dieses 28 Spieltags
zusammengefasst zu sehen ab Mitternacht
bei heute.de und in der heute App
Trainerwechsel bei Hertha der
Tabellenletzte der Liga hat sich von
Sandro schwarz getrennt ja und einen
guten alten Bekannten verpflichtet Paul
Datei
zum dritten Mal in acht Jahren setzt die
Hertha auf Pal Dardai als Trainer
Vorgänger Sandro schwarz hatte am Vortag
noch während des laufenden Trainings das
Vereinsgelände verlassen das 2:5 gegen
Schalke am Freitag war zu viel des
schlechten die Berliner sind am Ende der
Tabelle angekommen sechs Spieltage
Verschluss sollen wir es heißt neue
Reize gesetzt werden mit Dardai die
retterolle hatte er schon mal vor zwei
Jahren als geklappt die Hertha steht
dann doch nicht ab
das war schon Sport an diesem Sonntag
Dankeschön fehlt noch das Wetter morgen
gibt es im Süden und Südosten Schauer
oder es regnet leicht im Nordwesten
bleibt es trocken und die Sonne zeigt
sich länger die Höchsttemperatur liegt
zwischen 8 und 16 Grad auch in den
nächsten Tagen gibt es die meiste Sonne
im Norden und etwas Regen im Süden das
heute journal um viertel vor zehn mit
Dunja hayal ihr die gesamte heute Crew
wünscht Ihnen einen guten Start in die
neue Woche sag tschüss und empfiehlt
jetzt
Berlin direkt